what does that mean breaking in da I
don't know what that means
we had another comment come in on our
YouTube channel and we just wanted to
run it by you and see what your reaction
is and the person wrote I'm 33
I started making shorts when I was in my
20s I worked the way that Steven
Soderbergh works directing shooting and
editing right now I'm in a heavy
depression I had to move back home two
years ago after perusing film for the
past decade home is a tiny island I won
a 7-day film challenge in 2014 and a
best short at the film festival in 2015
I experienced sabotage from narcissistic
actors that I worked with they were so
insecure that they would rather ruin the
whole project and contain their emotions
and stick it out to the finish
I still work freelance as a V agra fur
in my country but I've been feeling
hopeless even if I've made a
breakthrough just the ability to keep
trying is so important and in my country
no one is interested in film and there's
no film industry it's just lectures
conferences a fun event here and there
maybe a commercial or a wedding I have
dual citizenship so I can always return
to the US but finding good-paying work
paying rent bills etc it can become
overwhelming as you're trying to be
creative I know I have what it takes I
know I can make a breakthrough I just
wish I was able to keep chipping away at
breaking into Hollywood what's your
reaction it's quite a story yeah I mean
it it almost kind of answers itself in a
way I mean it seems like this person has
confidence and they know what they're
doing and they know the the one thing
that's missing from that is any sort of
doubt whatsoever about their field and
what they want to do and that's they're
in good shape what does that mean
Breaking and I don't know what that
means anymore it's this abstraction just
by doing good work you're doing that
because if you look if you write
something exception
truly exceptional no one's gonna not
notice you want to I mean it's just I
don't think that really happened maybe
it does maybe I'm naive I don't know but
I think if you if you don't right toward
the validation and you just are trying
to create the best thing you possibly
can and you do that there's no way
people won't be able to pay attention to
it so I might if I find the advising
this person I mean I'm just keep working
and but don't don't look too much in
hindsight and in terms of who's screwed
you over and who's you know damaged
certain projects that shit's not going
to go away and it's that serving you in
any way by dwelling on it so just look
ahead I mean focus on what you're doing
and when you're looking ahead you know
just understand it's not gonna happen
the way you think it is I think that's
almost a hazing to see how badly you
want it
hazing by what the establishment or
whatever just doesn't even have to be
sabotage it just has to be that things
are not going to go as planned and
things can sometimes go very badly and
if you're able to withstand that okay
you've got your chip you've got not a
chip on the shoulder maybe maybe that's
helpful but you've got your little metal
now you can go on to the next one
something else gonna happen you almost
need that because it's it's never gonna
go as planned yeah no I see what you're
saying I mean I don't know I don't know
if there's a direct hazing that goes on
I mean maybe there is I don't think I
was hazed really but I think that la if
we're talking about LA and being here
the certainly tests you because you know
like if you're not from here most people
are probably not from here I guess I
don't know and and you come out the
typical story is that you come you've
got like three or four contacts and they
all do not pan out and they don't call
you back and then you're hearing like
what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do I'm on
this place and it can start to feel very
alienating I think that's the test that
I see most people go through is that
it's like six to eight months can you
withstand the loneliness can you can you
just can you withstand the sudden
strange
and find your people and find your way
or you're gonna hightail it I don't know
if there that's conscious I don't know
if I mean that obviously it's not it's
just situational but I find that those
who do overcome that period tend to find
their way and you know whether it's with
their people their friends their work
and all of it combined that's a really
good point and I thought of that Hey and
not just even just being here in Los
Angeles but just that projects are gonna
fall apart or yeah somebody's gonna be
upset with the way the cut of the film
was or whatever and just knowing that's
a lot of filmmaking and if you can
withstand that and graduate to the next
one yeah and if you've got a cut of the
film I mean you're in great [ __ ] usually
people screw over one another's projects
in the early stages and it's ridiculous
I mean it's like get to the point where
if someone's not screwing over your
project someone something's wrong I like
that that's really I don't know why they
do it I don't know why it's I mean but
it happens a lot yeah yeah I've heard of
it I've seen it happen yeah that's
that's a really good point
so get uneasy if somebody's not trying
to sabotage your project I guess yeah
and and learn what chain of title is
like really important learn what chain
of title is as a writer and when you're
supposed to sign it because writers get
taken advantage of I think more than
anyone maybe I don't know if that's true
more than actors but they do get used a
lot and there's safeguards you can take
so that's when you're signing a contract
to have a lawyer look over no chain of
titles like the title to your car so as
soon as you sign it someone else owns it
and I think there's I don't know
tendency whereas a thing but very often
like you know it's understood that if
you're a new writer you've got a you
know you get a help in the beginning and
you know you a lot of writers write on
spec in the beginning I mean I'd
certainly did and and you're you know
you're writing to be to do something
that's hopefully going to get made
knowing that it might not but I think
very often those people that are know
people who are trying to use writers
they will then be like oh like I need
chain of title just not assuming the
writer doesn't know what that is because
usually they don't have a business
background or a legal background and
then you sign it then it's gone so just
be very careful anyone ask you for chain
of title just talk to a lawyer
okay my advice
you